how do you choose a day whose company
would you enjoy well one thing you can
consider is looks like everything else
these days courtship has gone online can
that so-called science really find your
soulmate but I've never been out on a
dinner date before I'm just on line
dating is now a multi-billion dollar
industry
one in five dating relationships started
online but is there really a formula for
love it's 1959 and two electrical
engineering students at Stanford are
working on their final class project it
uses a questionnaire and an IBM 650 to
matchmake 49 men and 49 women they call
it the happy families planning service
there are no long term matches but they
do get an A for their work it was the
nineteen sixties where the computer
scientists started to get interested in
personal relationships and in particular
they were interested in whether they
could improve the efficiency by which
people match similar small data driven
systems appear but in 1965 it's
Operation match that really starts to
take the blindness out of a blind date
for three dollars you can answer over
100 questions about yourself and your
ideal date the answers are recorded on
punch cards run through a five-ton IBM
computer and a few weeks later you get
the names and numbers of your top six
matches computer technology has moved so
fast it matched on the basis of things
that people had in common so religion
hobbies attitudes to life in general and
we actually know now that that's not the
most effective way of matching people
six months after the launch 90,000
operation match questionnaires are
received making the company two hundred
and seventy thousand dollars
in 1995 match.com is launched by
American engineer Gary Kramer and then
in 2005 a group of employees at PayPal
create a website where people can upload
videos of themselves to try and get a
date the tagline is TuneIn hookup it
doesn't take off so instead it rebrands
itself as YouTube today Apple is going
to reinvent the phone it's 2007 and the
iPhone has just been released soon new
dating app start to appear racing apps
are notoriously private about algorithms
they use and that's because they use
quite simple one and they don't have
very much proof that any of them lead to
better matching they don't really want
everybody to find love on the first hit
because then they'd all be out of
business in 2017 around 40% of American
heterosexual couples first meet online
and by 2018 dating services in the US
are estimated to be a three billion
dollar a year business lots of people
anecdotally are saying they're fed up of
using dating apps but at the same time
business is absolutely booming the
number of users between 2016 and 2017 in
the world doubled even though they're on
the horizon the possibility of video
dating and augmented reality for dating
none of those things can give you an
indication of chemistry and you could
only find that out when you meet
somebody face-to-face that's still going
to be overriding with the way which
people meet and fall in love
[Music]
you